Jeff Bezos Elon musk's like someone
who's like typically Out Of Reach how
would you go about teaching somebody to
have access to that person I mean those
are really extreme examples because
those guys have everything and they
probably have a lot of people reaching
out to them so a way to get there would
be to have to go through like from the
heart so it's just continue to network
to to try and find out information that
are that's not as public about the
things that they like because anything
that is publicly known that other people
have already like gotten him his
favorite Jersey to his fit you know like
those are those are the obvious ones but
it's the less obvious ones and then
trying to figure out a way that just
like you're trying to get noticed and to
be fair it would still be hard because I
mean they are the richest men in the
world like the amount of money they have
is is hard to comprehend there's no
monetary value that can be delivered to
them and there's really no status value
that can be delivered them so it's like
how do I add value to someone's life it
would have to be from the personal